we have a voicemail number which is 2192
David P you can call anytime here's a
caller who has a very specific question
for me
David McCoy what would it take you to go
to a NASCAR race okay I have never been
to a NASCAR race I don't really care
about NASCAR I don't find it interesting
but I don't have any real opposition to
going I don't know if there are NASCAR
races in like the Northeast I'm just not
sure maybe up north like in Upstate New
York it's the type of I know Upstate New
York is is pretty conservative and Rural
maybe up there or not even Upstate like
Western New York Northwestern New York
maybe there I would go to an NASCAR race
it wouldn't really be for the racing the
racing seems quite boring but it would
be more as a socio-cultural I would go
as an anthropologist I think is what I'm
saying all right so if someone wants to
take me uh maybe we'll we'll document it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we're going to talk about the
rules package passed by Republicans
we're going to talk about what's going
on with IRS funding and Republicans and
we will talk about how Q Anon is
responding to the Brazil riots and more
when producer Pat joins me sign up at
join dot com get instant access it's a
great thing